this is the Galaxy Note 10.1 it's so
good in fact that we decided to compare
it to a pro camera this is the a7 3 one
of the best-selling cameras on the
market right now and it costs two
thousand dollars compared to eleven
hundred dollars for the galaxy note 10.1
also have to buy lenses for it the
Galaxy Note 10.1 an ultra wide lens
whereas here you actually have to buy
two lenses now these are very value
oriented lenses they're from Tamron this
is an ultra wide and this is a zoom lens
that goes from 28 to 75 which will
satisfy about what you can do on this
phone and one last thing the galaxy
notes in class comes with super steady
video which on the pro camera you
actually have to get a gimbal like this
one this is the Ronin ESC and it's
actually pretty new and it costs around
$500 and that's how you can get super
steady video with a pro camera so what
we're gonna do today is we're gonna be
comparing photos from this guy and from
the pro camera and we're gonna see if we
can tell a difference and to do that
we're gonna invite Angelica over into
the frame Angelica come on so she is
gonna be looking at a few scenarios of
photos and she's gonna be trying to tell
which one's the pro camera and which
one's from the galaxy note n plus
alright so this is our first scenario
using the telephoto lens and as you can
see both are very very bright I already
know which one is which but Angelica
which one do you think is shot using the
pro camera honestly I'm not quite sure
but if I had to guess I think I would
say the right one you'd say the right
one well in reality that's actually from
the galaxy note n plus so honestly it's
doing such a great job in this very
bright lighting you've got good contrast
you got good detail everywhere now we
have another photo shot with the
telephoto lens what's what do you
think's a pro camera I think the one in
the right is because I know that the
note 10 is pretty saturated you guys can
definitely see a difference here you're
seeing kind of more detail on the left
side but more saturation but watch what
happens when we zoom in instantly you
guys can see that the left photo is over
sharpen to the max and if you look at
the details you're seeing just so much
more detail on the right side
and that is why that is the sony a7 3 it
just looks so much better than the one
on the left and the Galaxy Note 10.1 so
which one is shot with the Galaxy Notes
and plus I think the one on the right is
is the phone yeah it's the galaxy what
do you think so again because of the
saturation and the details look better
on the left ones oh well you're actually
wrong wrong Wow here's how you can tell
which one is shot in the pro camera if
you look on the left side you can see
there's tons of details on all the trees
in the background but the Tesla's in
focus but on the pro camera the leaves
and everything the trees are all blurred
out and that's what you get with real
blurred from a real lens this is
actually a Bloody Mary we got at
dockside restaurant in Coeur d'Alene
this thing is 35 bucks
crazy crazy drink comes with so much
food and there you go left and right
angélica which ones from the pro camera
I think the right one is because the
left one is much more saturated saturate
it looks it looks pretty even to me but
you are actually correct the right one
is the pro camera but honestly they both
look really good and now we have a
selfie of me which one do you think is
from the pro camera I definitely the
left one the left one why do you think
so because the blurring in the
background is really nice it's really
sharp and pretty and those on the right
one there is a lot more like blurring on
your face kind of like smoothing out
which I know that the note 10 is kind of
made for it you are correct
yeah the left one is the pro camera and
one way we can tell is the blurring
obviously around my face and my hair
especially if you look on the right
photo you can see spots where the blur
got really messed up
honestly it still does an excellent job
but you can easily tell with those fine
little hairs and here's a live focused
photo of Max which one do you think is
shot with a pro camera I think the one
in the right is the right okay the
blurring the background is really nice
and there's still like a lot of detail
against hair and on a shirt yep exactly
the one on the right is the pro camera
and honestly
it looks so good so much better than the
one on the left now I think the reason
why the Galaxy Note n+ didn't do as well
is because of the tough HDR situation
they kind of had to really bring down
the highlights and the clouds to get the
clouds looking really good so the the
front and the whole face and everything
was just a little bit too dim and now
this is some special this is using super
steady video on the Galaxy Note and the
gimbal for the pro camera let's play
this back so which one is which I think
the one on the right is the Galaxy Note
10 and the one on the left it looks a
lot more stable yeah than the other one
I don't know if you guys can tell but
I'm actually running quite fast and Max
is running right next to me so we're
actually really impressed with how well
the super steady video worked on the
galaxy note n + C good here the Galaxy
Note tended Slive focus video Anjelica
which one is which wait till vyas the
one on the right is definitely the note
10 because the contrast is way too crazy
like your hair completely no detail and
it the blurring in the back is pretty
bad it looks really fake obviously the
one on the left just looks perfect it's
amazing this is the quality that we
shoot our videos with you get the nice
blur in the background this is perfect
for YouTube however even though the
galaxy notes and plus looks really
horrible like the video quality is a
huge step down from what you can usually
get out of the phone I'm actually really
excited for when a few years down the
road they're gonna get this down and
people are actually gonna start using
smart phones like this for putting up
videos onto YouTube so we're really
excited for that
now this one's gonna be really tough
this is a macro shot of a little plastic
plant Angelica which one do you think is
the pro camera this is a really hard but
I think I'm just gonna get the first one
is the pro camera because of the blurry
on the left side
actually you are wrong the pro camera is
on the right side so it's really hard to
tell and to be completely honest no it
looks good
no attended snails it's so amazing for
macro photos like this looks awesome and
this is the one scenario that we shot
with the ultra-wide lens jelka which one
is which I'm not quite sure but if I had
to guess I think the one on the right so
it's pretty hard to tell but the galaxy
note n plus is on the left and it's
doing excellent lens correction whereas
the pro camera does look warped and
that's even after lens correction being
applied to it so I don't know how
Samsung is doing this with lens
Corrections but it's completely nailing
it and the photo just turns out amazing
and here's another really tough one
angelica which ones which this is really
really hard
they both honestly look so good I'm just
gonna have to guess and say that the one
in the left is the pro camera you are
actually correct the one on the left was
the pro camera looks so good it does
look really good one way you can tell
the difference is with the notes hen on
the right all the lines are straight
they're not warped and the Sony is
warped like you can see the bottom of
that bench
it's warps it's like has this little
curve to it whereas on the Galaxy Note n
plus is perfectly straight which is
absolutely so impressive that we're
getting this good of a quality photo on
a smartphone I thought the right one was
the note because the details it was much
more detailed like in the break and
everywhere it looked like it was focused
everywhere and then in the darks like in
the plant and in the fan it was darker
now let's finish up with low-light
Angelica which ones which this one's
pretty obvious from my past experience
and the other video that I was in if you
haven't seen it yet check it out
the note 10 when it comes to like face
pictures whatever it really like blurs
out your face and does a lot of like
beauty stuff and the picture on the
right definitely has that there's a lot
of blurring going on so I think that's
the note smartphone cameras struggle a
lot in the night time and that's
something that is gonna be really hard
for them to overcome and finally here's
the last photo Angelica
which one shot with the pro camera
this is really hard the lights on the
top when you're pretty blown out but at
the same time I know that the galaxy one
doesn't do what's good in like dark
scenarios it doesn't keep as much detail
a lot of it's more crushed and you can
definitely see more detail in the trees
on the top one I'm gonna say the top one
is the pro camera actually she is wrong
the top one is the no 10 plus now some
of the differences you can see is and
all those neon lights the no 10 Plus
struggles to keep them nice and crisp
and clean and very colorful like you can
see that the colors are a little bit
blown out compared to the pro camera
which gets all the colors nice and even
but we actually have to bring up the
shadows and in doing so we introduced a
lot of noise into the sky which is a
downside with even pro cameras so there
you have it guys the galaxy notes and
plus is actually doing an excellent job
compared to a pro camera it's actually
getting close but not reaching the level
of a pro camera and to be completely
honest most people should just go with
this because you get an awesome premium
phone one of the best phones in the
world and you get the camera on the side
compared to spending that much money on
a pro camera which only photographers
should be doing because it's just
getting so good with smartphones these
days that just were really really
impressed so there you have the guys let
us know what you thought about this
comparison down in the comments section
below
be sure to check out some of our other
videos over here and click the circle
above to subscribe thanks for watching
and we'll see you in the next video
[Music]